[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france 24
notre invité aujourd'hui et pavel
filatiers f il a combattu deux mois en
ukraine dans l'armée russe il a ensuite
été blessés puis il a dénoncé dans un
récit l'opération militaire russe est
également le piteux état de l'armée
avant de prendre la fuite il est arrivé
il y a quelques jours en france où il
s'apprête à demander l'asile politique
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
parce que cette opération merci de votre
invitation alors on va revenir un petit
peu en arrière vous avez donc publier
votre récit sur internet sous forme d'un
journal de bord intitulé z sauver ce
sont les trois initiales qu'on trouve
sur les véhicules de l'armée russe vous
avez donné quelques interviews en russie
et puis vous avez décidé de fuir
pourquoi avez vous fui la russie
public et
livres en russe en internet de manière
ouverte je voulais attirer l'attention
des russes sur ce qui se passe
actuellement une crise où les leurs à
côté d'une manière tout à fait simple en
tant que participant à ces événements je
voulais leur raconter ce que j'avais vu
ce à quoi j'avais participé et tout
d'abord je n'ai intention de toucher le
citoyen un truc je voulais existants
tels que la société russe
réagissez les champs ce s'interroge sur
ce problème soulevé aussi que le
commandement se pose des questions sur
les problèmes que connaît notre armée
les graines malheureusement
quelques semaines de mons un show en
russie après cela j'ai compris que je
n'avais aucun recours
légal pour tenir pour parvenir à mes
fins et quand les menaces sont précisés
au bout de quelques semaines chef des
cités de décision quitter le biche ne
vais pas intention d'années en france
car georges choisissait un autre
objectif mais je n'étais pas de plan
précis en fait j'avais peur chez fuir
parce que je me suis dit que si on
allait me mettre en prison aurait
forcé que
de demain par des à feu et de dénoncer
en fait ma dénonciation
vous avez reçu des menaces précises
d'arrestations qui vous ont poussé à
prendre cette décision
un grand nombre est affaire qui sont
lancés quand
les chansons t'accuse et simplement
avoir appelé le l'opération spéciale une
guerre est en fait
ici jean cochet rédigé est extrêmement
menaçant pour le commandement russe et
aussi pour le la direction les
dirigeants du pays et à la dernière
minute avant de partir on ma
parce fait savoir que j'encourais une
punition de 15 ans voire plus et donc
j'ai compris à la dernière minute que
les avocats russes ne pourrait en aucun
code me défendre et que en prison jal
est contraint de revenir sur mes mais
mes dires alors après une péripétie vous
avez été aidé par une organisation non
gouvernementale vous atterrissez en
tunisie et l'a finalement vous décidez
de partir pour la france qu'est ce qui
vous a décidé de prendre la direction de
la france depuis la tunisie
j'ai été aidé par une organisation qui
se trouve actuellement france et qui
aide beaucoup de gens de champ qui se
trouve victime d'humiliations et de
torture et c'est une organisation qui
s'appelle goulag ou net et qui lutte
contre ces exactions
je me trouvais à tunis et ce sont les
services qui sont
sortis de l'hôtel en
[Musique]
avec des menottes et j'étais
menotté et j'étais
pris par les services il me considérait
comme ses services tunisienne risque
da en effet
je n'avais pas compris que ça mais ça
finit par se par apparaître et ensuite
il d'autres ils m'ont dit
que je devais quitter le territoire très
rapidement alors que j'avais simplement
un statut de touristes étaient
parfaitement légales je ne sais pas que
faire je n'avais pas de votre projet g
demandé à vladimir poutine qui se trouve
en france et qui
il m'a conseillé de venir en france est
de fait une demande à simon et par
bonheur la france ne me fasse pas et me
donne la parole alors vous arrivez donc
finalement l'aéroport roissy charles de
gaulle ici à paris et vous y passer un
petit moment et vous tourner une vidéo
dans laquelle on vous voit déchirez
votre passeport russe votre carte
militaire des documents officiels
pourquoi est ce que vous avez fait ça
est ce que il fallait démontrer de façon
visuelle votre rupture avec la russie
enceinte j'ai tenu bon kotov ses
poignets en anglais
jusqu'à présent je mon intention était
de d'être touristes ici à paris et quand
je me suis trouvé dans ces circonstances
me suis rendu compte que je suis ça
commence à charles l'école et les
métiers a réussi ce que l'occident
est notre ennemi et ont sabré nautique
j'étais contraint du fait de ces
événements j'ai été obligée de demander
l'asile dans un autre pays malgré le
fait que je suis un citoyen un militaire
de son déjeuner jamais centre venu un
règlement et aux lois de mon pays j'ai
toujours voulu être un citoyen directeur
de la société don t il je suis rendu
compte que je ne trouvais pas film
commenté ce matin j'étais furieux et
c'est dans cette étape j'ai appelé soit
déchiré ce document est chez nous
c'est de vidéo chat fait ce grand
ressentiment je me suis rendu compte que
je je suis contraint de quitter ce pays
alors que je suis un militaire je suis
un ancien combattant aussi échec j'étais
plein de ressentiment voilà pourquoi les
déchets ce document chez montrer que
notre gouvernement ça n'est pas notre
des nous et je suis
absolument contre et de voir que ce
gouvernement fait des actions qui ne
font pas dans l'intérêt de notre peuple
alors pavel fils à thiès vous êtes quand
même un cas isolé les soldats russes
visiblement ne déserte pas plus
généralement les russes semblent
soutenir ce que les autorités appellent
l' opération spéciale en ukraine
et acheter j'espère que ça n'est pas
vrai les russes ne sont pas en faveur de
l'opération speisser ne prennent pas ce
que le monde entier fois une image qui
est montrée par le gouvernement russe or
le gouvernement russe a la maîtrise
totale sur tous les médias y compris sur
internet et donne une image que c'est
une opération qui est soutenu par le
peuple or nous savons que toutes les
élections sont truquées à tous les
niveaux nous n'avons pas de médias
libres où on puisse s'exprimer librement
donc à ce gouvernement lancent eux au
monde une image dans laquelle tout le
monde est heureux de poutine et de sa
politique ça n'est pas vrai y ait une
majorité de gens qui ne sont pas
contents mills ont peur alors je vais en
revenir juste avant le 24 février vous
est basée en crimée 1 au 56e régiment
d'assaut aéroportée parachutistes
vous avez été avertis comment est ce que
l'on vous a présenté
l'opération spéciale
stop
événement et pour
montrer la manière dont les russes les
soldats ont été confrontés à cet
événement et la manière de les
contraindre à y participer en fait
personne n'a reçu d'ordre clair tout
était fait de rumeurs et dior une armée
russe qui ne répondent pas un loi
normalement la loi prévoit que nous
serons tu être prévenu aurait dû y avoir
un ordre du jour là et ça les militaires
doivent avoir le droit de refuser quand
nous avons été contraints de
faire
avancer et de se lancer dans une
opération dassault il n'y avait aucune
possibilité ni de de réfléchir la chose
et dans les premiers jours j'ai vu
l'ampleur de l'opération je ne croyais
pas à la menace de l'otan sur la russie
je me suis dit que peut-être ça n'est
pas vrai ce que je pensais que j ai eu
peut-être une véritable menace massive
de l'otan contre la russie
une semaine après le début
en étiez à personne et on nous a dit que
nous serions victime d'une attaque de
soldats de l'otan affecté
participants polonais brutalité autres
en fait l'information de l'armée est
minimale et c'est a fait une
désinformation
alors vous avez combattu dans le sud à
personne dans la région de mikolajki
alors on a eu des accusations on a
encore des accusations de crimes très
graves commis par l'armée russe abuja
borodianka plus dans le nord vous avez
affirmé que vous n'avez pas été témoins
de crimes contre les civils là où vous
étiez on a du mal à croire que l'armée
russe se comporterait différemment d'une
région à une autre
tac d'haddaway tumeur il faut que l'on
mette en doute
le fait que
l'armée américaine est
entièrement bonne entièrement noël en
fête dans tout art mais il y a aussi des
criminels il y a dans l'armée russe des
criminels et le gouvernement russe a
discuté sa propre armée
lorsque la communauté mondiale
lancée accusations le e gouvernement
russe n'a jamais pris en compte ces
accusations pour essayer de lancer une
enquête interne pour tirer les choses au
clair et le fait ou deux d'avoir refusé
de faire cette enquête a entraîné cette
généralisation voilà on peut donc appuyé
c'est tous les allemands de fascisme est
accusé tout les japonaises deux clics de
terre mais c'est le gouvernement qui est
en faute parce que il n'a pas
expliquer la chose après une enquête
véritable sur les véritables criminels
pour ce qui est de mon régiment il n'y a
pas de
preuve dans le champ
des monnaies diaconu qui
preuve que qui donne la preuve que notre
régiment et participer à ce genre
d'action et je peux répondre à ces
questions sur un détecteur de mensonges
et cela en direct sur votre plateau par
exemple alors j'ai pas de détecteur de
mensonge mais j'ai une une dernière
question sur vous maintenant vous allez
donc vous avez engagé une procédure de
demande d'asile politique en france est
ce que vous craignez pour votre vie vous
avez une protection policière est ce que
vous avez reçu des menaces au parler de
celle avant de fuir la russie est ce que
vous êtes en danger pavel filatiers
domota paca mais
je ne suis pas tu étanche n'aurait pas
été empoisonné par un novice choc
quelconque bien sûr je ne voudrais pas
que ça arrive on aura pas de de preuves
je sens cette menace mais je ne je suis
prêt à prendre le risque je ne veux pas
mentir je veux que mon thé xx améliorer
ce que je fais c'est dans l'intérêt de
mes
concitoyens je veux que les russes
soient
courageux et qu'il cesse d'avoir cette
attitude
d'attentes
de coire 10 et 2 attend juste toute
dernière question vous avez de la
famille en russie est ce que vous êtes
inquiet pour eux parce que vous prenez
la parole vous dénoncer des choses qui
comme vous le dites ne sont pas les des
choses considérées comme acceptables par
le régime russe
je ne répondrai pas à cette question
elle file à kiev merci beaucoup d'être
venu témoigner sur le plateau de france
et merci à vous d'avoir regardé cet
entretien sur nos antennes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]